i was wondering how someone who has just
graduated college and
is attempting a successful entrepreneur
i was just wondering what outlet you
would recommend they
learn business through
oh look who's arrived
it's savannah my daughter what if she
has a question
all right vincent but first a quick
music
interlude here i was thinking sort of a
[Music]
that's just a little ditty kind of a
bluesy ditty to sort of
cover up the sound of my daughter making
all that noise in the background here
but let's listen to vincent's question
vincent what do you got
hey mr wonderful this is vince mcgirey
again from
vinnie theory on youtube this is my
second question so i might describe
the first one but i was wondering how
someone who has just graduated college
and
is attempting to be an entrepreneur
a successful entrepreneur could go about
launching a product or starting a
business
in a way where they can learn business
through books or i was just wondering
what
outlet you would recommend they learn
business through
in a way that's actually applicable that
they can execute on
in a real business manner rather than go
to a school that teaches
you basically nothing that you're going
to use
once you graduate vince said i love that
skepticism about school there's nothing
wrong with school i'll tell you what's
great about school
business school is even or any
university or even high school people
you meet
you're going to forget what they teach
you but you're going to have those
relationships the rest your life
now to your question i wrote a book
called men women money i think it's
worth reading
it's a it's a short read but it gives
you a lot of basic principles about how
you have to deal with life
now having said that check that out on
amazon i think it's wonderful advice
actually it's three of them but try men
women and money the first one
now here's what i've always felt is
important
about entrepreneurship go work for
somebody else for a while
try out some business that you think
you'd be good at
and apply yourself to that don't
necessarily start up on your own for the
first time
that's a tremendous amount of work and
it doesn't always work out
experience is the one thing you can
never have
unless you spend time getting it you
know what i mean
and it's actually the most valuable
thing and something you should respect a
lot of people do not respect experience
i do i always ask mentors and people
that have done things before me
what i can learn from them now i'm not
against going to college
nothing wrong with that but the
experience of life of actually doing
something is the most powerful way to
learn
so get out there and do it again and i'm
not ignoring your first question that
was a good one too
i like all the questions we all learn
together that's what ask mr wonderful is
all about
but thanks for that one vincent music
interlude maybe maybe maybe what do i
got what do i got i'm thinking um
yeah maybe a little blues
[Music]
yeah classic those three chords d-a-e
all right sean what do you got let's see
hey mr wonderful two questions what are
your thoughts on using technical
analysis
when trading stocks and can one
realistically expect to become
wealthy off of trading alone thanks a
bunch
very interesting sean now you know
there's two schools of thought about
technical analysis that you can learn
from what happened in the past to a
stock price
by applying technical analysis to try
and determine what's going to do in the
future
i have not found that to be very
effective it's not that i'm against
it i do use charts a lot which are very
very
inexpensive you can get them for free on
any stock platform
just to see what the history has been
what the pricing has been
and obviously if a stock is very
volatile it makes me nervous in other
words there's a huge
change in fluctuation in price but
that's what traders like
now about trading to make a living
trading really
really really hard that's a fact
it's extremely difficult to make money
trading it's a it's a very nimble skill
i'm not saying you can't do it
i prefer to be an investor i own stocks
for the long term i use etfs baskets of
stocks and i even
do some fixed income with etfs on money
market things so i can get two percent
of my cash but
you know if you want to make a living as
a
as a trader to me it's akin to being a
gambler in las vegas very few make money
and i'm not saying you can't try i'm not
against it but for me it's not the way i
want to work
i would rather create wealth as an
entrepreneur in a business and then take
some of my proceeds and invest it in the
market to give me diversification
in the long run that's the only free
lunch in investing but i'm definitely
not a trader but if you are
good luck but you know try it for a
couple years if you can actually make a
living doing that maybe you can
go longer but i doubt it i'm a skeptic
sorry about that
all right sean
okay so here we are on the set of shark
tank and what matters is
what watch are you wearing that's all
that matters you look at the other
sharks
discount watches they have no story to
tell
they have no they have no fashion sense
but
check this out the seiko makes its debut
on shark tank it's absolutely beautiful
absolutely gorgeous look at that it's
tuned in
and now we have to listen
what matters on shark tank what head are
you writing with
what are your preference doing and what
watch
are you wearing this is the first debut
of the seiko the absolutely
beautiful lacquered red face with the
gold rose
spectacular works beautifully with these
fantastic tiffany gold and of course
this incredible mobile
it's all together making a fashion
statement and looks spectacular on
camera
that's the essence of philippines
there's only 150 of these this is number
110 all the sharks are jealous what can
you say
oh the sharks are jealous it's all true
lori um
so where's my face it doesn't want to go
over to you
it doesn't want to leave mr wonderful oh
wait oh there you go wait you're in the
wrong spot
lori what do you think of this watch
what do you think i like this watch
this watch is pretty it's made out of
like the blood
blood tips no the poison oh
that's right and if it explodes or
cracks or breaks he will get poisoned
over
that's kind of scary but yesterday he
was wearing one
it's kind of cool it looked like the
constellation
yes that was the ap yesterday that was
the perpetual
1159 with the red bed but today i'm just
loving the sake of
grand master it's just spectacular
yesterday's was my favorite though
oh she don't let the game segment hear
that
oh my goodness it might be insulting and
wait i'm gonna say my favorite pen
because of all of his pens i like the
beatles one oh
you don't like this one look at her
insulting my future is very unhappy
[Music]
ah i love this guitar absolutely
spectacular
yep it's a you know hess and dalton very
very interesting
handmade beauty um anyways
and today just out of interest i'm
wearing a blackface daytona with of
course the
customary red band for those of you who
are into watches hi mr o'leary
my name is george romero and thank you
for taking the time to answer my
question
here it is are there any circumstances
in which you would advise an
entrepreneur
not to make a deal with the shark
thank you so much wow interesting
we're good to go because they actually
want to get their money
you know i've never had that question
before but i'll tell you how i'm going
to answer it
i think you have to think about which
shark you want to work with
i think it provides a very important
platform
in america that
lets consumers discover new products and
services
and if you're just interested in
watching
the trends shark tank is probably the
cutting edge of what's happening out
there
there's constant innovation there's
constant new ideas
some of which have no merit but many are
amazing and so
and then it's up for the investors to
decide which or which is which and take
a chance on them
they don't all work out but when they
work
it's pretty phenomenal because shark
tank's been on for 11 years it's in this
11th season
so everybody knows every shark now i
know there's some guest sharks once in a
while but
the sharks that that are been there for
over a decade mr wonderful included i
might add
you've gotten to know by now and i would
do two things
if the deal makes no sense obviously you
don't feel like it's fair obviously you
don't do that deal
i like royalty deals i like venture debt
i like you know all kinds of different
structures because i'm the financial
shark
but i always let you know
entrepreneurs talk to the rest of my
company's ceos and
men and women that manage all the
different you know companies that i've
invested in
they're my best i think
people to provide due diligence and what
it's really like to work with mr
wonderful and i come up with some pretty
good grades i'm happy to say
they're my best salesman i mean all of
my ceos are my best salesmen we gather
every year but to actually not work with
a shark is
is because you've determined that they
don't add a lot of value other than
money to your situation the reason you
want to come into the shark world is
that shark can help you significantly
reduce your customer acquisition cost
by getting you out on their massive
social platform i've got millions of
followers obviously
and i love all my companies and you
constantly see me putting them out on
social media to tell people about the
new products and services that's what i
do that's how i add value
and of course i love to give mentorship
and i provide capital i do all that
and i have a great team of people
working with me
but the reason you wouldn't invest with
a shark is you don't think there's a fit
it's that simple but what a great
question
well that's it for this episode
of ask mr wonderful
oh isn't that sweet
go to the minor
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
anyway see you soon on ask mr wonderful
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
share share share pass it forward that's
what the mr wonderful youtube channel is
all about